[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES NUGENT: My
name's James Nugent.
I am product manager on the
Android Enterprise team.
Thank you all for coming
to both the conference
and also to this
session as well.
I promise it will
be very exciting.
Before we dive in, I just
want to get a quick feel
for the people who
are in the room.
So who here is from like a
Android manufacturer-- somebody
who makes Android devices?
Anyone from those?
Maybe not.
Anyone from like a Android
developer-- somebody
who develops Android
applications, perhaps
management applications?
Fair, fair few.
Anyone here from like
a customer-- somebody
who deploys Android devices
in their enterprise?
Trying to get a feel.
Few more there.
Who here came to see "Star
Wars" and is completely
in the wrong place?
[LAUGHTER]
I promise you it's
not as exciting.
But it should hopefully have
a few thrills along the way.
So I'm here to talk to
you about all the features
that my team has done in
the Android P release, which
has just shifted to a
developer preview a few months
ago specifically the features
relating to the enterprise
and work.
So our team had three key
themes for the P release.
The first one was related
to managed devices.
So these are devices that are
under supervision and used
in a work environment or
perhaps an education environment
as well.
These are things like
the work profile,
if people are familiar with
that, and also fully managed
devices when the corporation
will only own the device
and will kind of oversee
every operation that's
going on the device.
And a key process
within the areas
is device provisioning--
how do we enroll devices
into management and supervision?
The second key area
that we focused on
is around dedicated devices.
Now Android is open
source, very extensible.
And we've seen
manufacturers that
are pushing Android
into all sorts
of weird and wacky places.
These are devices that are
used for a single purpose,
so perhaps like an
airport kiosk or a device
that's used in the warehouse
for taking stock and taking
inventory.
So we made a lot of
investments in this
to sort of mirror the work
that our partners were doing.
And we'll talk about some of
the enhancements and features
we've done there with
a couple of demos.
And then finally security--
security will be a
race that never ends.
You know we'll continue
to invest here.
What's nice about the
work that my team does
is that the feature requests
that we hear from enterprises
around enterprise-grade
security just
go into the operating system
and permeate out to consumers
shortly after that
almost immediately.
So we'll talk about
some of the enterprise
features that are present
in the P release as well.
So let's talk about
managed devices first.
As I mentioned these
are types of devices
that are used by what we
call knowledge workers,
so people who work in an
office perhaps and want
to use either a device
that they bring themselves
into the office like a BYOD
type scenario or a device
that they're given
by their employer.
So one of the big
investments that we made in P
was really in response
to user feedback.
So back in Android
Lollipop, I believe,
we introduced the work profile.
This is where you
have effectively
a separate user
running on the device.
And you have very clear
segregation between your work
apps and your personal apps.
This is a type of work mode
that works particularly well
for BYOD.
So if you imagine
in my case at Google
I own my own personal phone.
But I want to get
access to my work email.
I can add a work profile,
get access to all
my corporate applications.
But my employer
has no visibility
into any of the
personal activities
I'm doing on the device.
So as I mentioned this has
been a feature of Android
since Android Lollipop.
And some of the feedback
we got was around
improving the user experience.
There were some
challenges in this area.
So firstly you'll notice on the
screen in the left-- it's just
a screenshot from
Oreo-- that all
of the work and
personal applications
are mixed together.
You can see that
there's a small badge
icon that's used to denote
the personal calendar
versus the calendar.
So that is the
personal application
versus the work application.
And we heard from users
it's hard to parse
this duplicate list.
You have this long
list of applications.
You have a personal
email and a work email.
People didn't understand
the difference.
And this bright orange briefcase
felt slightly disconnected
from the Android system UI.
So we made some changes
to that around that in P.
So firstly work and
personal applications
are separated into separate tabs
within the launcher themselves.
So that's kind of an
inbuilt filter between work
and personal modes.
You'll notice that the
briefcase icon is now
changed to a nice shade
of blue, more in line
with the overall
Android system UI, which
using hints and hints
of blue here and there.
And you'll now notice that
we have a toggle right
up front and center
on the work tab,
giving users the ability to
turn off the work profile.
So you imagine the use case here
is that it's Friday evening.
And I no longer want to
receive any notifications
with work chats or email.
I can simply turn
off the work profile.
Those apps are
instantly suspended.
I no longer receive
notifications.
And then on Monday morning
when I'm back in the office
and I want to resume, I simply
turn that toggle back on.
But you can also
see at the bottom
there's a clear
indication that this is
the remit of my organization.
Their management only extends
as far as these applications.
And they have no
sort of visibility
into what I'm doing
on my personal side.
So just to expand
across this as well,
we've added some user
education to make people
aware of this new paradigm.
So the first time the
launcher is opened you'll
see this blue tab
that informs that this
is the new home for
work applications.
And as mentioned there
before, this toggle
to turn off work applications
is kind of up front and center
with some demarcation
as to say this
is where your organization's
remiss kind of extends to.
So I want to switch to
a quick demo of this
over on the WolfVision
if possible.
So this is a device
running Android Oreo.
Just unlock it here, quickly.
So you can see here that I
have got just a regular home
screen with a launcher.
And when I open the home
screen, open my launcher,
you can see I have
duplicate Chrome icons,
I have duplicate contacts,
duplicate calendar, here,
there, and everywhere.
So you can imagine that's quite
difficult for users to parse,
and you may have
accidental clicks
as the user could
select the wrong icon.
The actual ability to
turn off the work profile
has been available
since its inception.
It was actually buried up
here in Quick Settings.
It's already two swipes
down there, and then
a further swipe to the
right to turn off Work Mode.
At this point,
work notifications
have been suspended.
And now, when you
open the launch,
you see these sort
of strange gray icons
everywhere, which
is not ideal at all.
So let's compare that
to a device running
P. Just unlock this quickly.
Sorry.
So again, you know, the
familiar Android home screen.
I can swipe up, and now I've
got Work and Personal tabs,
so all my work, my home
applications are here,
I've got my personal photos,
my personal email, et cetera--
no duplication of applications.
You can see that
Android is continuing
to suggest applications
to me at the top,
and that will go across
both Personal and Work.
You can see there's the badged
icons up here at the top.
But now in the work tab
I have everything kind
of grouped together neatly.
There's no mix and
match of applications.
And on a Friday
evening, when I want
to go home and
have a beer, I just
simply turn off the
Work applications,
and everything stops.
And then switching it
back on, very simply,
back to the Work tab
on Monday morning,
and I have to unlock
again, sadly, but--
whoops.
And all my work
applications restore.
I can now start
getting emails, sadly.
So if we could go back
to the slides, please.
So the behavior I've just
described there is actually
part of the default
system launcher
that will launch with
Android P, but if you're
a developer of
your own launcher,
you too can sort of join in
in this experience as well.
There is an API to request
Quiet Mode enabled.
That's what's turning on and
turning off the Work profile.
And when that
action is initiated,
there's a couple
of broadcasts that
go out to the system
itself to say,
like, Work profile is available
and Work profile is now not
available, and the launchers
can use that to kind of change
the colors of icons, and
mark apps as disabled.
Any application can query to
see if Work mode is enabled
by calling that API there,
is Quiet Mode enabled,
and there's further
documentation at that shortlink
if anyone's really
into more details.
So the next piece of feedback
we received from users, again
related to the sort of dual
persona of applications
that you have as a
result of Work profile,
quite a lot of users
have this muscle memory
of using the Account Switcher.
If you have multiple
accounts on the device,
say a personal account
and a work account,
most users are sort of used
to expanding the sidebar menu
and toggling between
the two account views.
With the Work profile,
because there's
such separation
between the two users,
previously, there
was no visibility
from the Personal side of the
Work user, and vice versa, too.
So in Android P we've
introduced this ability
to be able to switch
between the same instance--
sorry, a different instance
of the same application
that kind of exists
in both profiles.
So in this example, as you're
seeing with the animation here,
I've got the Google
Tasks app, and you
can see that I've got
both Personal and Work
tasks I need to perform.
So on my personal side I've
got a dentist appointment,
et cetera, and
organizing my wedding.
On my work side,
when I switch over,
you can see that I need
to submit my expenses
and cancel my
one-to-one meeting.
Now previously,
the user would have
to return to the home screen,
find the other application,
re-launch the application.
But thankfully from
Android P, any application
can develop support for this.
So there are some critical
APIs to support this.
The first one is
getTargetUserProfiles.
That will return a list of the
available user profiles that
were on the device.
Typically in a Work
profile, there would only
be one additional user profile.
We provide some
icons that you can
use to facilitate
the sort of smooth UX
during the switching
process, and you can also
get a localized label to say
that this is the account you're
switching to.
When the application
is ready to launch,
you simply call
startMainActivity,
and that will launch the
instance of the application
inside the other profile.
And again, full documentation
at the shortlink.
But what's crucial about
this is it's not just limited
to Google applications.
Any application that
would potentially
reside both on the personal
side and the work side
can implement these
APIs, and you too
can kind of implement
this seamless switching
between the two instances.
QR provisioning-- so one
of the focuses for our team
is how do you enroll the
device as quickly as possible.
So you can imagine I'm
an IT administrator,
I've got a crateful of devices
that I need to provision,
and give out to my employees
as soon as possible.
And we support a number
of mechanisms around this.
There's NFC provisioning, there
is zero touch provisioning,
which was launched last year.
And one of the methods we've
supported for some time
is QR provisioning.
So this is where administrator
can generate a unique QR
code containing the details
of the Enterprise Mobility
Management solution the
enterprise is using,
and that begins the
enrollment process.
What's new in P is the ability
to include Wi-Fi configurations
within that code.
So historically, if
you wanted to add
the Wi-Fi configurations, you'd
have to enter those manually.
And secondly, what's
most important about this
is actually the QR code
reader itself is bundled
in the operating system.
So historically if you wanted
to use QR code provisioning
to enroll your
devices, you'd have
to first connect to Wi-Fi,
entering manual credentials
to do so, download some QR code
library to start the process,
and then finally scan the code.
Now the good thing about
this is it's actually
an improvement of 30
seconds per device,
because the QR code library
is included in the OS,
and you can actually bootstrap
connectivity straight away.
So if you can imagine
30 seconds per,
and you've got 1,000
devices, that quickly
becomes quite a
large time saving.
What's nice about the Wi-Fi
configurations is that if that
Wi-Fi access point
is within range,
the device just connects
immediately and the enrollment
process continues--
Setup Wizard just
continues to go through.
We support a number of
different Wi-Fi credentials,
so things like the
name of the SSID,
the password, any proxy
details you want to specify.
That all can be
encoded in the QR code.
What you might notice that
certificates are missing.
So this is an early
piece of feedback
we've got from partners
since presenting this,
and that's something
we're looking to address
in the next Android release.
And there is full documentation
on that shortlink there.
So when we speak to IT
administrators and customers
that deploy Android devices
in the organization,
we get constantly asked
for additional hooks
and additional
tools that they want
to configure on their devices.
One of the gaps in
Android for some time
has been around the Access
Point Name, the cellular APN
that you need to add
to a device sometimes.
So if I am a large
corporation, and I've
got a strategic
deal with a carrier,
and they may be given a
custom APN, historically that
would have to be
a manual process
to add that into the device.
But now we can do that over
the air through the EMM.
And we've actually given
more control to the settings
there to the IT
administrator, particularly
around the time and time zone.
So we've heard about all
sorts of abuse scenarios
where, if you imagine,
say I'm a truck driver,
and I've got an
Android device, I
may want to adjust the
time settings on my device
so that I appear
to be on a break
and I would know
when we push jobs.
So suddenly we're clamping down
on that practice in Android P.
There's a full list
of methods in terms
of what we support
here, and more
in the linked documentation.
So there's an ability to add
what we call an override APN--
that's a custom APN,
and then enable it.
There's APIs to set the
time and set the time
zone, and a whole selection
of additional policies
that we've included
to kind of lock down
certain aspects of the device.
That ranges from disallowing
Airplane Mode right the way
through to disallowing printings
if your organization has
a problem with people printing
spurious amounts of paper,
we now have the policy for you.
Further features we
built into Android P
is the ability to
migrate the DPCs.
So for those of you
who are not familiar,
a DPC, or a Device
Policy Controller,
is what the Enterprise
Management tool will actually
install on the
device, and that's
the actual application
that's enforcing
all these different policies.
Sometimes it may be
appropriate for a customer
to migrate to a different
DPC, and there's
a couple of reasons
why that might happen.
So it could be
that my management
provider is migrating from
an old stack to a new stack.
A new version of
their DPC is required.
So this could be--
we now have the APIs to
support that migration.
Secondly, the
management provider
may be moved into the
Android Management API.
This is something we
launched last year,
and provides a much easier
way for management providers
to offer the full suite
of management services
on their device.
So again, that could be
another case for DPC migration.
And then finally it
could be the case
that a customer is actually
switching from one management
provider to another, and they
need to install the new DPC,
and transfer everything over,
and maintain all the policies.
They'll be no loss of
policy in this case.
OK, so let's talk about
dedicated devices.
So as I mentioned,
these are the devices
that are often used
for a single purpose,
or maybe kind of a
ruggedized hardware that's
been augmented with
bar code scanners
and all kinds of things.
We see lots of innovation in
this space within our team.
So one of the most popular
modes for devices of this type
is something we call LockTask.
So this is locking
the device to only
be able to be able to use
either one or a handful
of applications.
So you can see on the
left-hand side here
there's an example
where a device is being
locked to be a point of sale.
In the current experience,
LockTask mode only
supports a single application.
So you're only able to lock
to one application at a time.
That's certainly
not ideal, and what
we started to see with
some of our partners
were implementing
workarounds around this
because locking
to one application
probably isn't
the best solution.
And what happened
was those workarounds
tend to be quite flaky.
We would change
something in the OS,
and those workarounds
would simply stop working.
So it was the right
time to invest
in a platform-wide solution.
And then secondly, the
application developer
themselves, so in this case,
this Point of Sale application,
had to declare explicit
support for LockTask mode.
They had to include something
in the application that said,
I actually support
LockTask mode.
Now what happened here is,
because this wasn't perhaps
the most--
people weren't
aware of this mode--
there's not a consumer feature--
application developers
simply didn't include this,
and that severely limited the
catalog of applications that
could be used in LockTask mode.
So anyway, as always,
good news comes in P.
So LockTask can now support
multiple applications,
and we have a custom launcher.
So we can see here that I've
selected six applications,
and the user is able
to use these things
and come in and out
of them as they wish.
Any application can be
put into LockTask mode.
So here I've got
Chrome and Maps.
The Chrome and Maps
developers have
had to do nothing to
support this LockTask mode.
And then finally, we have more
flexibility around the launcher
in terms of what UI
elements are shown,
and the administrator has
full control around this.
So they can either choose
to show the Home button,
they can choose that certain
settings are enabled,
or they can lock
everything down,
and there's no way for the
user to use these things.
So I'm going to give
a quick demo of this
if you wouldn't mind
switching to the WolfVision.
So a good example
of LockTask mode
is devices that are
locked as a kiosk.
So this is something
that could be,
say, like an airport
or a library.
So within Android P we
now have support for this,
and it's actually a very
secure model as well.
So when the user has actually
stopped using the device
or chosen to end their
session, that entire user
is actually deleted, so all
their data goes with them.
So let me give you a quick demo.
So you can-- here
there's some sort
of-- there's a
splash screen here.
This can be fully customized.
I've just given a very simple
example here for Google.
And then off we go
to start a session.
I've got to apologize.
This isn't the most
glamorous demo.
I've only got two applications.
But you can imagine that
one of the applications
could be like a
Help application.
And you can see here, this is
just the applications here.
So when the users actually
finish their session,
they can simply hit
End Session, and that
will clear all of
that user data down,
or you can wait for the screen
to time out, in which case,
that process also happens.
And what you can actually
see here when it says,
ending session, is that
process of deleting the user
and actually creating a
new user in the background
so that when the device
returns to the splash screen
a new user has been created,
and the next session
can start straightaway.
So that's the first session.
Go back to the slides, please.
Thank you.
Sorry about that.
A similar but slightly
different example of this
is around shared devices.
So you can imagine, perhaps
that I work in a supermarket,
and I work the morning
shift, and I pick up
a device in my morning, and I
use that to check inventory.
I'm walking around,
checking the shelves.
I log in with my credentials,
and I have access
to my applications.
At the end of my
shift, say 2:00 PM,
I put that device back
on the charging cradle,
and then the person who's
working the afternoon shift
picks up the same device, logs
in with their credentials,
and they're off and
running as well.
The crucial difference
is here is this.
My application data would
remain entirely separate
from the second user.
They wouldn't be
able to read my email
or even see any of
the kind of inventory
scanning that I've been up to.
And you know, we provide a
very simple way for users
to log in and out
of this experience.
So let me give you a
quick example of this.
So here you can
see, you can imagine
I pick up a device in the
morning, and I log in.
I've got a very
secure password which
I'm about to show you here.
You can see I've got
my applications here.
So again, very similar
to the earlier example,
but I've got my selection
of applications here.
You can see, actually,
I've got my email address.
There's an email
saying, Hi, Ian.
So I could go about,
continue my duties,
finish whatever I need to do,
and at the end of my shift
I would just
select, End Session.
Sinduran comes along, he
logs in with his credentials.
Again, we enforce very
strict password policies.
So if I log into
Sinduran's email,
you can see there is an
email from Ian saying hello
to Sinduran.
Again, there's no visibility
of each other's data.
It's effectively two
separate users on the device.
And again, when
Sinduran has completed,
you just simply log out.
So there's obviously mechanisms
to add new users to the device.
So you can imagine that the
user may pick up the device
and scan a bar code to
log into the device.
We also support signing
in with a Google account,
and I believe we
also support logging
in with third-party
authentication providers
as well.
One of the pieces of
feedback we hear from users
of dedicated devices--
so I mentioned these bar
code-type devices that we see
in use--
is around maintaining
control of their fleets
during business-critical
periods.
A good example is
the holidays here.
So the last thing that they want
to happen is for an OTA update
to come and affect
all the devices, cause
a bunch of regressions to
their internal applications,
and suddenly on Christmas Eve,
all these applications are
kind of failing, and
people can't make sales.
So for dedicated devices, we now
introduce this ability for them
to postpone--
sorry, let me start again.
For users of dedicated
devices, we've
now given customers
the ability for them
to postpone updates
for up to 90 days.
Why 90 days?
Why did I pluck that
number out of anywhere?
It's really for November,
December, January.
That's kind of
that period there,
and we end up with 90 days.
Now you know, I'm sure you've
been to other talks at Google
today where we talk about
the high investments
we're making in security,
and how we want devices
to be updated all the time.
So you can imagine
introducing something
like a 90-day freeze period kind
of goes slightly against that.
We want devices to be updated.
So to prevent devices being
locked out indefinitely,
and hopefully
receiving an update
once this freeze period
is over, we introduce
a 90-day cooling off period.
There's a 90-day buffer
between any freeze period.
So in that time, any
kind of OTA updates
that are being
postponed or frozen out
would be pushed down
to device and applied.
So this avoids the situation
where I've been indefinitely
locked out of the device.
That's a state we don't
particularly want to be in.
And then all the new features,
all the new security updates
that comport with
the platform update
will be applied during
this cooling off period.
And then finally, on
security, as I mentioned,
this is an area where we
will always invest in.
There's a bunch of new
features in this area.
So let's start with the
separation of the work
challenge.
So you may have
noticed, actually,
when I re-enabled
the Work profile
on one of the first demos, I was
prompted to enter a password.
That's the password
that the administrator
has required that I have to
enter to use the Work profile.
The administrator can actually
specify some quality arguments
around that password.
They can specify that it
has to be a certain length.
It could actually be
a very long password.
Now what happened in
previous versions of Android
is if an administrator
has said, right,
if you want to use
the Work profile,
you now have to use
a 12-digit password.
That would then manifest itself
as the device password as well.
So every time you want
to unlock your phone,
you're having to enter
this 12-digit password,
and then have the same again
to access your Work profile.
So, not desirable, most people
want to use a fingerprint,
or maybe a short password,
or short pass-in,
so in P we've kind of split
these things up a little bit.
So admins can require
different pins and passwords
for the Work profile versus the
actual unlocking of the device.
So it's a bit of
a usability win,
but maintaining the
security integrity
around the work profile.
Data leakage is a
consistent concern.
We hear from customers who use
Android Enterprise devices,
particularly in
highly-regulated devices
or highly-secure organizations.
So we continue to plug gaps as
they come up to our attention.
So what we're actually
introducing in P
is some additional controls
about what data can be shared
in and out of the Work profile.
So many people will be
familiar with the Android share
icon, the Share Intent.
We're now giving
administrators the ability
to turn off either one direction
going out of the Work profile,
or into the Work profile,
or in no directions at all.
So we've got full flexibility as
to what the direction in which
data can travel.
We're also giving
administrators the ability
to prevent extracting
data via ADB.
So those of you who've used
Android De-bug Bridge, this
is where you connect your
phone to your host PC,
and you can use that to
debug certain information
on the phone.
Administrators flagged
to us that this
could be a potential
security risk,
so we now have a policy where
extracting data from the Work
profile by ADB can be disabled.
Verified device
access continues to be
a key feature around security.
This is when a device
is perhaps communicating
with a remote server.
It has to strongly
attest to its identity.
So you can imagine
where a device is
kind of signing into
a remote server,
it's maybe identifying
itself using its IMEI
or its serial number
to retrieve whatever
configuration it needs to.
The difficulty is,
IMEI and serial number
can be quite easily spoofed,
and it could be the case
that the device has
been compromised
and is kind of misrepresenting
itself to the remote server.
So devices like the
Pixel now support
hardware-backed authentication.
So we now have APIs in
the platform as well.
So as well as presenting
my hardware identifiers,
I can also present a
key or a secure hash
for those identifiers that
are a strong indication that I
am the device who
I'm claiming to be.
So we now have APIs
in the framework that
allow you to use either
Google's keys or your own keys,
and certificates to
authenticate to remote services.
And then finally, not the most
sexy feature, I do apologize,
but when investigating
incidents or security breaches,
administrators like the ability
to interrogate log files
on the device to understand
what's being going on.
We now have unique identifiers
for both network and security
logs.
So the reason for that
is that if the logs have
been somehow tampered with,
or logs have been removed--
or entries have
been removed, sorry,
they will be easy to
detect because there
will be some sort of
discrepancy in the unique IDs.
And then finally we've
expanded the coverage
of security-related actions.
So there's a sort of additional
level of security actions
that will now be added
to the log files.
There's even more listing on
security at that short URL.
I'd encourage you all to
read it at your leisure.
So in summary, there are
lots of great features coming
in Android P. I've
talked about the three
key areas our teams work on,
so things with the managed
devices, the Work profile,
fully managed devices,
dedicated devices where
we see a lot of innovation
from partners that you wouldn't
expect, and then finally,
security.
Everything I've described
here is public information.
Feel free to take photos
or get started with it.
It's all part of the
Android P release,
and there's full documentation
and developer guides
at Developer.Android.com.
[MUSIC PLAYING]